Now, another request we've heard
from a lot of you guys
is that right now it's
a little bit challenging
to move data
in and out of App Engine.
If you've got a lot of data,
such as something
in an existing database
that you have on site,
it can be hard to get that
into App Engine's datastore
to start playing with
and testing apps.
So in response to that, tonight
we're excited to announce
our large-scale
data import tool.
This tool makes it really easy
to move gigabytes of data
into the datastore
in App Engine.
You can start, stop,
or resume your upload,
and it handles errors
that you might encounter
as you're sending a lot of data,
possibly over the course
of a few days.
Now, we're also
working on an export tool.
So it'll be just as
easy for you to move
the gigabytes of data
you have in App Engine
off and have
a local backup copy.
After all, it's your data.
You should be able to do
anything you want with it,
to move it on or off
as easily as we can make it.
Now, the next feature
I'd like to talk about briefly
is particularly exciting
to our enterprise developers.
One thing we've heard from
a lot of enterprise developers
is they'd like a way
to connect to the data
that they have
behind the firewall.
The stuff they haven't
put in the cloud yet.
In fact we've heard from
a lot of enterprise developers
that they feel like
they're being forced to choose--
to choose between
having applications
that are easy to access
in the cloud,
or applications that have
the security of data
behind the firewall.
Well, we don't think
you should have to choose.
So tonight,
I'm excited to announce
the Secure Data Connector,
or SDC.
SDC makes it easy to have
policy-controlled access
in your applications
to your on-premise data
that's behind the firewall.
Now, before I get
into a more complicated, uh,
description of how SDC works,
I wanna show you
an example of SDC in action.
Now, uh, I'm also
a manager here at Google,
so I sometimes
have to manage my reports,
and I might need to see
a report of my employees.
So here we have
a sample spreadsheet
where we've imported
some employee data
that lives behind the firewall.
Now, this data here is not--
has been changed,
so this is not
real employees' data,
to protect peoples' privacy.
[laughter]
So you can
get off the phones now.
Um, but it is actually
coming behind our--
from behind our firewall.
You can see from the url
this is actually
coming from within Google.
Now, we've set up a policy
on this spreadsheet
that says that I, Kevin Gibbs,
can access this spreadsheet
and through this spreadsheet
can access that url.
The policy is very specific.
And due to that policy,
and the fact that I'm logged in,
which you can see
in the right-hand--
the upper right-hand side,
I can actually do a query
in this spreadsheet
and the spreadsheet will be--
and the query will be
sent through Google
down to inside the firewall.
So lemme try a query, here.
And you can see it'll
actually send out that url
and return some new data.
Now, that's really--
once the page loads--
that's really
all there is to it.
As you can see, the import data
commands got a url in there,
that u--and the
Secure Data Connector tells it
how to find the right url
and return that data.
That's it.
That's all you have to do.
And really that's
part of the beauty of SDC.
It's really easy
for you to set this up
and gain access
to your firewall data.
You don't have to
set up a proxy,
you don't have to
change your VPN,
or do anything like that.
In fact, sort of
the magic of SDC
is that you can use this app
in the airport
and gain access
to that firewall data.
Now, I'd like to now tell you
a little bit more
about how SDC actually works.
'Cause it's pretty important
given the security involved
in what it's doing.
SDC is built around
having an agent
that runs inside the firewall,
and a set of servers
that run at Google.
The SDC agent then connects--
You run the SDC agent,
and it makes a connection
to our servers in the cloud.
And that gives the servers
at Google access--
policy-controlled access
to the data
that you've chosen to expose.
That means that
Google App Engine applications,
gadgets, and spreadsheets
can all have access
to the data that you specify
in your policy.
We wanted SDC to be
straightforward to use
while still giving you
the security that you needed
to run your application.
And so that lead
to a few design goals
that we have for SDC.
One, we wanted SDC to be simple.
Want it to be simple
for you to use.
And that--for that simplicity
is embodied with two things.
One, we wanted to make it
easy for you to run the agent.
All you need to do
is take our agent software
and install it on any Linux
machine within the firewall.
Once you do,
it'll connect and authenticate
with Google Apps
and make the data available
to anything else at Google
that you've granted
that permission to the data.
Within applications,
whether it's a spreadsheet
or an App Engine app,
or what have you,
it's very easy
to use SDC as well.
All you need to state
is the url that you wanna reach
and Google will
automatically route it
down through the agent
within your firewall.
Now, the next goal
with SDC was security.
Obviously, for a tool like this,
making it as secure as possible
is one of the most
important considerations.
That's why all the data
that you send with SDC
is encrypted with SSL.
But it also means that we wanted
to make it secure
for your organization.
That's why when you use SDC,
you don't have to open
a new port in your firewall
or change anything about
the settings of your network.
It only makes outbound
connections to Google.
And finally, we wanted
the policies that you use in SDC
to be very specific.
That's why the policies
are at the application,
user, and url level.
That means you have
very fine-grain support
over exactly who, uh,
can access any of the data
that you've exposed.
Now, the final consideration
we have for SDC
is we want it to be open.
So to achieve that,
we've actually open-sourced
the entire SDC agent.
You can go
and check out the code now
and audit it yourself
if you'd like.
We've also chosen to use
the OAF protocol
when authenticating
from the server to--
at Google down
to your agent software.
The OAF protocol
is an open standard
that has seen a lot
of public scrutiny.
And we think that it represents
the best practices
in authentication.
Now, I've shown you
a really simple example of SDC.
I'd like to now
call up Mark from Oracle,
who's gonna show you
a real-world example
of using SDC to connect
to seeable data.
Mark.
[applause]